Hey youtubers is Charlie, and the first
promo for Legend Of Korrathe Book 3
just aired in the Netherlands on Nickelodeon.
It was mixed with footage from books 1 and 2
but I wanted to do a breakdown of all
the new things we saw.
And what it means about
the premier for Book 3 in the United States.
Once Nickelodeon officially announces
whenever it's going to premiere in the
United States and North America,
which is by going to be in June, I'll start
doing more regular Korra videos so be sure
to SUBSCRIBE to get everything :)
It's going to be a lot of fun. I think
it's gonna be a summer show this year.
So let's answer some of the big questions first, Number 1
Why did this air in the Netherlands and why
are we just seeing it now and why are the
creators not saying anything about it?
Mostly because this footage was a promo
for the Book 2 Premiere
in the Netherlands. That's right, they're
just now getting Book 2 Spirits in
the Netherlands.
The reason why no one is officially
talking about it is because the
Nickelodeon office in the Netherlands is
responsible for making these promos
so Bryan and Michael the creators
have nothing to do this kinda stuff.
So that's why they're not talking about it
They'll be a lot more publicly vocal as well
as the actors like Janet Varney whenever
an official US version of the trailer
drops, which is going to be soon!
Now to the really important stuff what
was that new footage.
Here is the breakdown.
First, Floaty Korra in the Avatar State. #2
Korra is in Republic City
using her water bending to pacify
spirits see the Spirit Vines that the
dark avatar grew in the finale?
Yep they're sticking around. They're
going to be the homes for the spirits.
#3 - We see Korra fighting the White Lotus
#4 - Korra is fighting regular Earth Kingdom
soldiers.
#5 - Shirtless Tenzin air bending. Say what
you will, I'm sure JK Simmons was smiling
whenever he saw this LOL.
#6 is a shot Korra, Bumi, Tenzin, Jinora,
Bolin and Asami exiting one of her
airships. They're going to use those to
travel around the season.
A lot of you actually asked about Aang's
children still being a part of Book 3 and
here's your answer. The trio will still
be together even though Kya is not in the shot.
#7 - A White Lotus member talking to a
Dragon, this means dragons are back
just like the Sky Bison in Book 2. We'll
have to wait for an explanation as to
how they survived.
#8 Korra fire bending against another
White Lotus member.
This could actually be one of the main
villains of Book 3 or it could just be a
sparring partner.
and #9 - The final shot is a Dragon flying
past a mountain fortress
in what looks like the Fire Nation.
Dragons are native to the region so it
looks like we're going to get some Fire
Nation time in addition to Earth Kingdom
stories.
So what does all this footage say? Well the
White Lotus is heavily involved in the plot
of Book 3. They could be the villains or
they could be working with Korra. It's hard
to tell based on these few clips.
The other big takeaways are that the
Fire Nation and the Earth Kingdom are
huge destinations for the story
as well as dragons being integral part.
The biggest questions I have now though
are #1 Are the White Lotus the new
villains or
if they're not how are they involved
with Korra in the story and #2
How are the Dragons involved with them?
It looks like they're working with the
White Lotus.
Now it's your turn, let me know what are
your biggest questions based on this new
information?
I'll be doing a Legend of Korra Q&A next
week so just leave all your questions in
the comments below.
Like I said, once they announce an
official premiere date for Korra Book 3
I'll start doing more regular videos, which
I'm expecting to be either the end of
May or early June.
There are a couple big things and I'm really
looking forward to seeing that official
trailer though, you know namely
Opal the Earth Queen! While we're waiting for
that, everyone make sure to go back and
watch Last Airbender Book 3.
There's a big White Lotus storyline in that
book. Right now click here for all my
Book 3 videos. I've done several so far.
and click here to learn about my Top 5
Anime Villains. Thank you so much for
watching, I'll see you guys tomorrow!
High Fives :)